Neil and I were quite excited because I
got an email from my acquaintance artem
saying that it was possible to make
sodium chloride blue I mean a blue color
not some sort of classification
and his recipe
was slightly vague
that you mix sodium chloride and
potassium chloride and heat it until it
melts
this in itself is quite difficult
because the melting point of sodium
chloride is higher than the melting
point of a test tube
however if you mix it with potassium
chloride you get a mixture which melts
at a lower temperature than either pure
sodium chloride or pure potassium
chloride
it's a so-called eutectic mixture so
Neil mix them together and started
Heating
as he started heating the bottom part of
the mixture began to melt but the top
part was still rather solid so he used
an extra gas gun
and it got really hot and everything
melted and the test tube which was
straight began to bend
fortunately glass does not have a
precise melting point
so it still was intact
so the recipe says that once you've got
the salt molten melted you need to drop
in a grain of metallic sodium
now a grain was not very specific
so Neil chose a piece
and I thought it was about the right
size
we dropped it in
and there was quite a bright flash of
light
[Music]
and it continued to flash sometimes it
pumps with light with a sort of orange
color which is probably the color of
sodium vapor like you see in sodium
lamps because the temperature of the
salt was well above 500 degrees
Centigrade
something's going on in there celsius if
you prefer once the sodium had appeared
to dissolve we could see that there was
a bluish color on one side of the test
tube
we hadn't mixed it very well
and Neil
wasn't very enthusiastic about trying to
Stir It
so we left it once it had cooled we
needed to get it out
and as you might have guessed Neil chose
the hammer
[Music]
and out came the sodium chloride
potassium chloride and sodium mixture
once it was cooled down it was obvious
that the sodium chloride was slightly
blue
so the experiment worked there is still
the quite a lot of arguments
why the sodium chloride goes blue one
argument is that if you have excess
sodium you will have spare electrons
and the solid goes blue there's
definitely some blue in there rather in
the same way as when we dissolved sodium
and liquid ammonia and it went blue it's
like ink yeah yeah so the sodium wants
to lose an electron let's be sodium plus
it's much happier being sodium plus the
other argument which is probably the
more likely one is that you make very
fine particles nanoparticles of metallic
sodium which are distributed through the
solid
and these nanoparticles satellite so
they look blue when at the end Neil put
some water on the sodium chloride there
was some fizzing
presumably that was excess sodium that
was left I think that the experiment was
quite a success it wasn't perhaps quite
as blue as we did hope
but it demonstrates quite an interesting
feature about materials that usually we
think materials have precise chemical
formula like
NaCl
but it is possible to make these
materials with a bit more sodium or
probably a bit more chlorine as well and
the properties will be different in this
case the color
[Music]
so Neil and I both felt we'd learned
something
and of course Brady always learned
back into the uh the cold bath just to
stop all the ammonia from boiling off so
we've got cut some sodium up we had a
big lump of sodium cut some bits off
that and we're gonna put smaller chunks
in this is going to go in there